[Música]
y hoy es directo a vamos a ucrania con
nuestra enviada especial catalina gómez
ángel y es que hoy comienza la semana
número 12 de la invasión rusa una de las
ciudades más golpeadas en toda la guerra
es mariupol allí
1730 militares ucranianos especialmente
del batallón asof se entregaron a los
rusos según el ministerio de defensa de
rusia aunque varios comandantes siguen
resistiendo en la planta de asof tal
causa entonces han y pro con nuestra
periodista catalina bienvenida y
cuéntenos por qué es tan importante
mariupol
marie paule tiene un significado
diferente según cuál es el país que lo
mire para los rusos y especialmente para
el presidente vladimir putin podría ser
la única gran victoria que ha tenido en
estos tres meses de guerra pero a qué
costo al costo de una ciudad destruida
de cientos de personas muertas de
cadáveres en la calle de personas
viviendo totalmente en la miseria
atacando a las personas que intentaban
salir de allí y para los ucranianos si
bien esos 1.700 hombres que han salido
hasta hoy según dicen los rusos hombres
que defendieron a muerte su país están
en una especie de rendición o evacuación
como lo llaman los ucranianos también
ayudaron a crear ese sentimiento de
esperanza de lucha y de resistencia
ellos su lucha hizo que las fuerzas
rusas se enfocarán toda su lucha en ese
puerto sobre el mar de azov y
descuidarán de cierta manera esos otros
frentes como el área de kiev o por lo
menos que no pusieran allí todas sus
fuerzas lo que terminaría por el final
que las fuerzas rusas terminarán retirar
del norte del país y también de áreas
como jarquín bueno y el 24 de mayo se
cumplen tres meses de la guerra
cuéntenos cómo están los frentes de
batalla sobre todo porque ha habido
muchísimos movimientos pasaron de la
región capital de kiev a irse al sureste
del país cuéntenos cómo están esos
frentes
según los analistas en este momento la
guerra en ucrania podría estar en entrar
en un momento de estancamiento después
de esos avances que hicieron las fuerzas
rusas por el norte en la el área de kiev
y dejar kif hoy en día realmente la
lucha está basada y centrada en la
región del donbass allí también las
fuerzas rusas han tenido que disminuir
sus expectativas cuando comenzó esta
primera fase se dijo que iban a tomar el
control y a rodear toda el área del
donbass sin embargo con el pasar de las
semanas estos avances no han sido como
ellos esperaban la defensa ucraniana y
esto también en parte por la llegada de
muchísimas armas occidentales ha sido
bastante fuerte y hoy en día sus
esperanzas y la gran lucha celita se
limita a la parte más este de la región
del donbass donde si bien van avanzando
poco a poco también tienen una gran
resistencia de las fuerzas ucranianas
así que lo que podemos ver en las
próximas semanas según dicen los
analistas es que esta guerra llega a un
punto de balance donde se armen
posiciones de defensa de lado a lado y
podemos entrar en un momento en que esta
guerra se alargue por mucho tiempo
catalina gracias por todos estos
detalles desde ucrania y nosotros
seguimos aquí en france 24 con más
información en directo américa